across the continent Russia advances its
political and economic relationships
with little regard to the rule of law or
accountable and transparent governance
it continues to sell arms and energy in
exchange for votes at the United Nations
China uses bribes opaque agreements and
the strategic use of debt to hold states
in Africa captive to Beijing's wishes
and demands autismo dugouts DF delves
deeper into this story disregarding that
it reads more like a declaration of war
than a strategy this plan is for the
good of Africa promises john bolton this
coming from a guy who is boss trump
infamously referred to several african
nations as something that i can't
mention on air the predatory practices
pursued by china and russia stunts
economic growth in africa threatened the
financial independence of African
nations and posed a significant threat
to US national security interest it's
interesting logic so when China or
Russia or someone else you don't like
lends an African nation money that's
debt colonialism almost financial
slavery when America does it its
investment Africa's own good
worth mentioning is that Russia's trade
with the continent pales into
insignificance when compared to the u.s.
or China look at this rail line this
highway hydropower station all built
with Chinese investment Beijing is
raising entire cities with more to come
China is willing to provide another
sixty billion dollars in support of
Africa through government assistance
investment and financing of financial
institutions and enterprises the phrase
actions speak louder than words is
entirely applicable here the Chinese
leader Xi Jinping has visited Africa
nine times during his tenure Trump once
sent his wife but what the United States
might lack impact
it more than makes up with guns American
troops stationed in 50 out of 50 for
African nations it has 34 military sites
thousands and thousands of soldiers
across the entire continent and a long
history of military interventions China
has one base in Djibouti Russia has none
American troops are there for Africans
own good Washington would say speaking
of which you remember the whole Chinese
and Russian money bad American money
good thing well it turns out not so much
our new foreign assistance strategy will
ensure that all US foreign aid in every
corner of the globe advances US interest
countries that repeatedly vote against
the United States and international
forums or take actions counter to US
interest should not receive generous
American foreign aid john bolton ladies
and gentlemen man who unveiled America's
new Africa plan so much for financial
independence Africans good luck
Trump administration does not actually
desire to help Africa develop they see
Africa as a pawn on their geopolitical
chess board and therefore they want to
use Africa against Russia and against
China China and Russia policies in
particular China with the new silk road
is not predatory China is actually
building massive infrastructure projects
across the continent but the New Silk
Road or the Belted Road initiative they
are transforming the continent so the
real policy would be for the United
States to join with China instead of
following a very cynical geopolitical
strategy which has nothing to do with
Africa and everything to do with the
United States trying to maintain the
upper hand against Russia and China
ah the only thing we'll do is we'll push
people in Africa closer to working with
other people
you